if you're watching this on the day it
comes out and you live in the US we want
to let you know that it's not too late
to get some microcosmos products in time
for the holidays at microcosmos.store we
have expedited shipping available on all
of our products except the microcosmos
microscope but to guarantee delivery of
your sticker pack or coffee mug by the
24th you'll have to place your order by
tomorrow December 20th so go to
microcosmos.store now if you're still
searching for that perfect gift for
Grandma
foreign
feels a little bit like watching a cat
waffling back and forth between whether
or not it wants to take a nap sometimes
the baronema stretches its body
undulating into an elongated
Indescribable geometry as its flagella
twitch like whiskers and then sometimes
it curls up into a cozy Circle tucking
one end into itself the way any feline
friend you might know curls up around
the perfect beam of sunshine
when James our master of microscopes
began his journey with his first
microscope he found parinema in their
elongated form but for some reason
whenever he went to record them under
higher magnification the paranema
reverted to their curled up form James
did not know why he guessed like many
microscopists before him that this
Behavior had something to do with the
intensity of the light after all
switching to a higher magnification on
the microscope requires shining more
light on your sample and the more light
that James Shone on the perinema the
more he saw it curl up when we looked
more into the bits and pieces inside of
peranima we were surprised to find that
it actually had something in common with
us and with how we see the world it's
always thrilling to find something in
common with microbes even if it
shouldn't be surprising if you go far
back enough in The evolutionary history
of human beings you will hit upon the
ancestors we share with paranema or
other present-day microbes and sometimes
we have similar traits not because we
inherited them from the same ancestor
but because nature itself is repetitive
it finds ways to make motifs out of
chemicals and sometimes evolution is a
funding combination of both of those
things
take for example the family of organisms
that perinema belongs to the euglenoids
a perennial favorite on Journey to the
microcosmos because of the fascinating
shapes they take on thanks to a series
of strips made out of protein that run
the length of the organism if you are
new to the world of euclinoids you may
notice something starkly different in
some of these species some of them are a
very Vivid green which makes them stand
out like bright patches of grass against
an otherwise flat background and this
sets them in distinct opposition to the
colorless euclinoids like perinema which
scrunch and wiggle and dance in the same
unusual way but they are definitely not
green now other than this very
definitive color difference colorless
euglenoids share a number of traits in
common with their green counterparts
they use their flagella to Glide and
swim most use the constant shifting of
their bodies as a way to move around the
microcosmos a motion called metaboly so
why are some green and others not
well the answer goes back to some
ancient euglenoid that developed its own
photosynthetic organelle not by making
it from scratch but by absorbing it from
something else most likely it consumed
some kind of green algae millions of
years ago and then instead of digesting
its meal it absorbed the algae and its
chloroplasts into its own body until
they became one organism the process by
which these green euglenoids got their
photosynthetic blasted is called
secondary endosymbiosis an absorption of
an algae that had absorbed a
cyanobacteria like a nesting doll of
photosynthesis or a poem that references
itself as it unfolds and as far as
motifs of the microcosmos go the
recurrence of endosymbiosis is one of
the most dominant and consequential we
have seen it over and over again as we
explore the evolution of mitochondria
and chloroplasts and it sets up a
particularly important divide among
eukaryotes those who can make their own
food and those who cannot the green
euglenoids with their photosynthetic
plastids are able to make their own food
converting sunlight into the molecules
that sustain them and form the basis for
entire ecosystems but the parinema
they're like us they cannot make their
own food so they have to hunt it down
and they're very good at it if an
organism is small enough the perinema
will simply swallow it whole and if
their prey is too large for that the
paranyma will use a part of its mouth
called the rod organ to cut its meal up
into a more digestible format and this
need to gather or hunt for food is not
the only thing that we have in common
with parinema as we said in the
beginning that unusual curling Behavior
we saw happening has its roots in
something else we share with these
unusual microbes rhodopsin
for humans and in fact for many animals
rhodopsin is a protein that plays an
important role in our ability to see
things converting the light that hits it
into an electrical signal that our
brains can process into an image and
radopsin proteins with similar sequences
have been found in all kinds of
organisms including green algae and
fungi and it turns out they are also
found in paraneoma but the paranema
doesn't see with its roodopsin receptors
at least not the way that we do instead
when light hits the rhodopsin receptors
it sets off an influx of calcium ions
which in turn drives the organism to
curl up into a ball this behavior is
similar to the way that bacteria and
archaea use rhodopsens to control their
tendency to reverse directions when they
come across light and the fact that this
protein appears again and again in
different organisms makes it a
fascinating way
to learn more about how Evolution has
shaped and reshaped similar components
into different tools because sure
something might be common but that
doesn't mean it can't be fascinating
indeed very often means the opposite
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you also to
those of you who've been doing holiday
shopping at microcosmos.store I am very
excited to know that so many people are
going to unwrap a microscope this
Christmas because getting to spend time
with my microscope finding out what's in
my backyard what's in the Little Pond
down the street that's been one of the
best things about being a part of this
channel now at this point most of you
have probably finished your shopping and
also we're not going to ship you a
microscope in four days but for those of
you who are hoping to pick up some
microcosmos merch or some new plan
objectives for your loved ones it is not
too late as long as you live in the US
and you can pay for two-day shipping it
will arrive by the 24th as long as you
order by tomorrow as of this upload
December 20th so if you're still trying
to figure out what the heck to get your
dad for Christmas why not head over to
microcosmos.store pick up a new coffee
mug some cozy lacrimaria socks
the people on your screen right now they
are our patreon patrons and I want to
say thank you to them it's been another
wonderful year of Journey to the micro
Cosmos we've had a great time we've
learned lots of things there's even been
some legit science published in
peer-reviewed journals if you'd like to
be a part of what we do here and help us
continue sharing the wonders of this
marvelous microscopic world you can go
to patreon.com journey to micro if you'd
like to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]